hi I'm Chris waters joined by Mary Kish
Mary good morning good morning ah let's
talk about claptrap Borderlands the
pre-sequel you and I got to play
yesterday I played as claptrap you
played as Nisha yeah dual wielding
that's right got these like sweet ornate
guns uh we'll talk about Nisha another
time it's all about the robots Sasson
people so you place claptrap and like
they've said before your your point of
view was a little lower but here we see
this is what I want to talk about really
he's shorter he's the night he's now
turned into a pirate ship on this
footage and this is vault hunter exe his
action skill and what it does is selects
from a random package of unlocked
abilities and so this one what's these
four cannons around the sides of the
screen starts playing the 1812 overture
that's right and just starts to shooting
cannon circle mix of something that's
actually really helpful in battle but
incredibly funny and enjoyable because
the explosions do go off to the beat so
it's like denon in a nun in it don't
don't and you get this like awesome
awesome feedback from the cannons that
are attached to all corners of your tiny
body it's delightful and apparently he
liked also looks like a tiny pirate ship
when that happens I was you can see it
in the first person view but that's just
one of the different things that his
actions skill kind of it analyzes and
chooses based on what's going on so I
think I was facing a badass enemy there
we brought out the big guns but I you
Hugh were around for another one it was
a grenade party yeah he's he's such a
fantastic enjoyable character because
he's always like kind of like this
slurms mckenzie like oh like it looks
liven up the party and for some reason
we're all in this intense battle and
it's getting really heated and people
are starting to dial around us you me
need some help and he just says grenades
for everyone and mix it and just throws
grenades onto the ground I actually
needed a bunch we were fighting a boss
it was really helpful and I just
gathered them all up I'm and
and just started throwing bombs out left
and right another one that maybe we'll
take a look at is I turn into a rubber
ducky so like the cannons were intruding
on the view before a giant rubber duck
head just pops up and you're always
bouncing now you as me show you like you
still get to experience the kind of like
floating pneus of the pre-sequel because
you're on the moon there's less gravity
there's people are foot stomping
everywhere I love the butt stomping it's
a great additional mechanic that I've
really enjoyed when in doubt but stomped
joven air bus stop a really nice AOE
around your ass and I find it really
enjoyable I had ice on mine so every
time I but stomped everyone around me
froze gave me a lot of time to be able
to take them out you had a few different
types yeah well I did this one right
here you see is a corrosive damage and a
party obviously it's a fart joke because
of borderlands so that one's really
amusing and then when you're the rubber
ducky you're always bouncing so you can
just but stomp butts dumb but stop all
the time like crazy so playing this
claptrap you it's that action skill the
vault hunter exe introduces this kind of
randomness but they're all helpful I
mean another one is he just throws down
a little turret like Axton in the
original Borderlands and it just arts
shooting tons of missiles out at any
enemy there you saw a second wind skill
that like sends out a tiny little
explosive homing claptrap to just blow
up whoever's nearby very helpful for
getting a second wind yeah I noticed
that often you do end up depleting your
life pretty easily you can get taken out
quickly but you rarely need to restart
you can easily get a second wind as
claptrap kind of like just encouraging
you to go for it and another thing that
I really love klepto kind of like this
controversial character sometimes some
people love him some people hate him I
love the fact that is Nisha when I was
playing with you I was able to give you
the old male a high five that was one of
my favorite parts of you
claptrap and being able to do this
together so that was a skill at the end
of one of the trees and basically what
laptop does is he like goes up for the
high five and then you decide you want
to melee me back all right then now we
both get bonuses to health regeneration
and fire rated sorry that's right if I
may lay you back we actually get bonuses
because we enjoy each other but if I
want to like hey I'm Tom are you what
you screw you guys and then I only I get
the bonus and I go off and to help it's
best to like claptrap apparently so
claptrap new playable glass in obviously
Borderlands the pre-sequel we've got
more on the game coverage coming on
gamespot com so keep a lookout for that
here from pax prime
you